anyone who's sort of engaged in any
thing that would fall under the the
label of next gen right whether it's in
in a startup or not in the large
corporate you need to be aware that a
it's an uphill battle it's literally an
uphill battle uh and and it's a marathon
run it's it's not a quick one right it's
it's a journey
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillary stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders meet orrin
marmer as vp and general manager of the
payments line of business at finastra
oren is leading the payments growth
business delivering end-to-end payment
solutions to customers globally and
promoting the product modernization
journey towards a cloud-based platform
and ecosystem
orin is the talpiot alumni the idf elite
technology training program okay
oran marmer welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you today i'm doing great thank
you michael for having me here
general manager of payments at finastra
but with an
exhilarating career previously with
mdocs and before that
as ceo and rent running companies and
basically being you know throughout your
career both as an entrepreneur as a
senior management working in large and
small companies seeing different
technologies
breaking through glass ceilings and and
that is the topic of our conversation
today breaking through glass ceilings
and and working on on cutting edge
technology both on on a personal level
but but i'm also curious to hear from a
leadership standpoint through specific
examples what does that even mean to to
lead teams that are working on
next-generation concepts
that are non-trivial so oren give me a
very brief background about about
yourself as as a thinker as an engineer
as a leader and then we'll dive deep
into you know two or three specific
examples from your career where you were
working on these next generation
technologies absolutely yeah i think
maybe you know in order to explain that
you know we need to go back as as always
and i've heard some of your previous uh
episodes and it always starts from the
army right definitely here in israel so
i know a lot
from the army yeah exactly so so i was
part of the uh tokyo program which i
think you know back then was still also
known i think by now is even even better
known and i think if you look at the
concept of that program it all has to do
with on the one hand picking
folks that are very strong on the
technology side and love you know to
push innovation and push boundaries and
so on but they can also be leaders and
and i can tell you that i remember we
heard stories i was sort of in the in
the 12th year of the program but if you
look at earlier years
sometimes if you pick the brightest ones
they're not necessarily team players or
can lead people and so on so it's all
about finding the balance and i think
this is if i sort of look back i think
this is by the way where when it started
but i realized that on one hand i love
technology i love innovation i love you
know learning new things
but i love this to be practical right
you know i never really thought although
my father is a professor in the technion
or you know was a few years ago
but for me you know i you know i
never really related that much to the
theoretical stuff it had to be practical
and for me you know doing things with
people seeing the passion uh driving new
things engaging with the market
disrupting markets uh succeeding with
customers this is really what i'm truly
passionate about how do you really take
an understanding of what the market
needs and then the market is constantly
evolving new technology innovation and
people to drive it all i think it's an
amazing combination not an easy one to
crack and usually most of the challenges
are how do you really combine all of
these together
perfect so in order to set the stage as
we dive into some examples of of leading
in in next generation technologies let's
define what that means what does it mean
to what what does the next generation
technology mean and what challenges
would would this perhaps pose for a
leader
you know i think you know next gen is
it's a broad term but i think that what
we're seeing across the market first of
all one of the terms i always like and
there's so many
lectures around that is that innovation
is not only amazing in itself but
innovation itself further accelerates
the pace of change right and then it's
it's part of yeah
financial growth right so the more the
more we innovate the more we introduce
new things uh uh the faster we'll be the
cycle until we get the next change and i
think what we're seeing uh is we need to
remember the technology while it's
amazing it's not the the goal it's a
means the net right it's about
serving
uh a customer needs you know making
lives better uh engaging better in
between people and so on and i think
that if you look at all the markets i
spent the majority of my career in the
telecom space
and that market is completely disrupted
you know i think there's uh a big
question mark of whether telecom service
providers will exist in the shape they
are today in 10 years from now because
at the end of the day they are becoming
what we call fat dumb pipes right and
and most of the value lies elsewhere so
it's innovation here is not just about
if we take the telecom example not just
about providing you know 3g and 4g and
5g and greater speeds it's about how do
you really engage things your customers
differently how do you allow
new business models how do you tap into
new domains how do you create an
ecosystem of partners that allow you to
create additional value and these are
challenges that span you know well
beyond just the technical aspects
themselves
it's about how you really
understand so have a forward-looking
view understand where the market would
be in two or three years from now and
provide technology that will truly
provide real business value to your
potential customers
all right so it's time to dig deep into
some examples so so oren
let's talk about a few times where
you were working on something that was
new that was different that was in the
next generation
and and i'm i'm curious to hear
both how you experienced it as a leader
but also how the people that were
working with you experienced
uh
experienced it as well
i i think that first of all
anyone who's sort of engaged in any
thing that would fall under the
the label of next gen right whether it's
in in a startup or not in the large
corporate you need to be aware that a
it's an uphill battle it's literally an
uphill battle uh and and it's a marathon
run it's it's not a quick one right it's
it's a journey uh and i think one of the
uh uh key things is that in many cases
that you sort of you need to work on so
many friends together on the one hand uh
have the vision the technical and
technology vision and pushed out
technology on the other hand you need to
do a lot of market education because
sometimes in order if the more
innovative you are
the less people understand at early
stages what you're trying to achieve so
you need to sort of not only show them
that what you're doing is good you need
to convince them that there's an actual
a problem and they they
they need to do that and you know a
great example is uh um you know for uh
my i just until recently i was at amdocs
for for about six years for the first
five years i led the uh
network virtualization
business so basically in a nutshell is
how do you take the traditional telecom
networks and move them over to the cloud
you know so cloud is now disrupting all
industry people and telecom operators
realize that
yeah rather than just uh you know deploy
uh proprietary boxes and have and be
extremely limited in terms of their
ability to introduce new services and
and react quickly and and so on you can
now move many of the uh telecom
functions into as as applications into
the cloud now when we started when i
joined amdax in 2015 and we started the
sort of this concept just came out of
incubation from the cto office and there
was a decision to start making it a real
business uh and it was literally an
uphill battle both internally within the
company because you need to sort of
rally rally you know the sales guys and
the sales folks and and and they you
know they're driven by short-term quotas
but you need to sell them on a
longer-term vision as well as the market
you would come into
a lot of customers and definitely when
you deal with
large-scale tier one you know customers
and it's true probably for every segment
in the market uh there's
almost this automatic resistance to
change right you approach a cto or an
executive at most
of these uh customers you know the only
thing they want to do is uh you know
whatever works for the past couple of
years will work for me until i finish my
tenure and you know let someone else
worry about that so it's uh it's it has
also to do with uh convincing that there
is a compelling event and you need to to
find the early adopters that will help
you uh optimize and fine-tune the
solution by the way it's from my
experience what's amazing about this as
much as it is an uphill battle
there is always an inflection point you
know there's the amazing uh malcolm
gladwell book tipping point it's exactly
that phenomena right it's you get to
that point you can never forecast
exactly in advance where it is but once
you show a few early wins then sort of
everybody hops on because no one wants
to be left behind they start seeing
their competitors sort of uh
operate in in a different destructive
way
but it does require a lot of
vision forward-looking planning and a
lot of tenacity you go through so many
ups and downs and uh
you get so many no's along the way but
uh
it's really about you know dedication
true belief and and the end goal and and
and creating enough sort of of uh
of uh rallying enough supporters around
you that share that same vision to help
you get through that period of time
now when you when you were doing the
saddam dawgs out of the cto office how
how did you cultivate
this sense of belief and rallying the
troops not necessarily to the hundredth
person but to the first person or to the
second person you know that because you
essentially need to build a
you know group of champions around you
that are going to
be as resilient as you are
i i think by the way and i've done this
in previous companies in the past it i
think it all starts from uh a personal
connection okay at the end of the day
you know we always say it's one of those
cliches that you know uh although we uh
work is work right and families have we
spend much more time at work with them
than we spend with our families right
and friends and so on uh so by the way
for me you know it's not that you
necessarily have to to be best friends
with everyone at work but i i you know
for me an integral part of work is
working with people i believe in and you
know i feel
uh you know uh excitement and fun to to
come and read it
so the same goes here you know
specifically with field uh functions
that are more sort of customer facing
sales marketing business development and
so on it's about creating the personal
trust you know for them a lot of people
don't realize that their greatest asset
is their reputation if you're gonna
push them into selling something
eventually you cannot deliver they will
lose their reputation and it might
impact their career moving forward and
this is probably one of their main
concerns so it's all about
not just sort of going through the
formal channels but creating a lot of
personal connections let's uh exciting
them about the the joint opportunity
making sure that they understand that
you're you're there to to really back
them up and not just to take a risk at
their expense
and usually i think whenever you do that
sort of you know eye level personal
connection
let's create you know a common goal
let's all engage together it becomes
much easier to do
so what ended up happening with it so
where what what did you
you know achieve either through the
specific you know technological problem
that you were trying to solve or
internally within the organization uh i
mean first of all we had an amazing
journey there so we started with as we
said a concept that was pretty much on
paper and then uh you know a year a year
or two years into the process we we
already had that deployed at some of the
largest customers around the world you
know comcast att
uh uh
certain affiliates of vodafone globe in
the philippines and so on and it's it's
amazing you know you sort of uh it
becomes sort of uh a rolling effect of
you know every every additional customer
you win the next one becomes a bit
easier uh it's still you know a long
journey and and when you're destructing
the market it always takes time until it
really hits sort of mainstream uh but uh
it was amazing to see it and i've had
this privilege of seeing this several
times through my career it's amazing
that the satisfaction
of
remembering where you started you know
with things being on paper theoretical
you hear all the reasons of why not you
know not how how can you actually do it
and then at the end of the day were you
sort of standing at the top of the
mountain and sort of uh
feeling uh so uh satisfied with the with
what you've achieved is is worth you
know all the hardship throughout the way
i love it now today you're general
manager of payments at finastra finta
company and so what i'm what i'm curious
about is how do you cultivate this
culture of
of breaking glass ceilings as general
manager now and especially as you're
you know looking at payments within
authentic company how are you
cultivating the sense of innovation and
you know
through leadership or through whatever
it may be
how do you go about doing that
especially as you're new
to this field
right
so first you know maybe i'll start with
a short uh sort of sentence of what drew
me to to join finance and i think that
could help
and and you know i remember when i when
i was approached regarding this
opportunity it sounded exciting by the
way i was as much as i love the telecom
space i also love to learn new things so
and fintech is definitely hot you know
globally is this and specific here in
israel so it sounded like an amazing
opportunity but as i was sort of started
diving deeper and learning a bit and
then i met throughout the process the
entire management team of the company i
realized that it's amazing that it's
going through the same disruption the
telecom space is going through and then
when you look at it
we all know what banks are today there's
a big question mark of whether you need
banks in the future right because uh
we have you know i think most of us that
they are much more attached to the
payment apps on our phone than we are to
our bank account right you know it's
much more intuitive
and so on so i so i realized that while
i you know i'm i'm i don't have deep
knowledge yet of the specific space the
trends what cloud is doing what digital
station is doing you know the the uh uh
expectation to have a different customer
experience from the end consumers it's
almost identical to the trends uh we're
seeing in the telecom space and this is
where i knew you know i could i could
make a difference here because uh it's
it's exactly the example of just giving
you from amdocs and i think this is the
vision i'm trying to
convey here is that
you know think big you know understand
you know sometimes
a lot of the engineers and the folks
that are working very hard are sort of
so deep into this release and this
feature and this capability and so on
they tend to lose uh you know a bit of
the view of the big picture and and and
we're trying to constantly make sure
that they understand that we are here to
disrupt the market the financial
services market is being disrupted
whether we want it or not and i think
we're enough in astra as being one of
the you know the largest uh fintechs in
the world and we're serving 90 of the
100 largest banks and have over 9000
customers and so on we're in an amazing
position
to enable our customers to go through
that disruption and come out of it
stronger okay and this is where again it
goes back to how do we migrate into the
cloud how do we allow an ecosystem and
allow you know accelerating innovation
into their environments and and so on i
think that by itself is an exciting
opportunity
so what is perhaps one thing that you do
as a leader
either on a day-to-day basis or on and
off
that cultivates this sense of both
responsibility for what you're doing in
the day-to-day but but always aiming big
shooting you know going for the moon
shots and you know at the end
innovating to be to continue being a
market leader in the space which is as
you're mentioning constantly evolving
um
you know what someone once told me when
you think of it you know if you ask a a
developer right or a software engineer
they know what they deliver right they
deliver a code you know what what do we
as managers or executives deliver
and it's mostly decisions right this is
our main deliverable we we need to
decide to make shots and i think one of
the things i'm trying to to apply here
is that uh let's not leave things up in
the air let's decide if if if it's not
clear let's cut it one way or another
and i'll i'm also a strong believer and
fail fast it's it's great to fail as
long as we we've done it for the right
reasons you know we're not repeating the
same mistake twice
we learn from it and we do these
improvement cycles quickly because the
the you know the procrastination is the
worst thing if we just wait and wait and
and and wait until we have 100 of the
information the decision will in most
cases be irrelevant because
circumstances have changed so many times
yes
i i love it
take me back a little bit to your
childhood before talking before the army
before working at all these great
companies
where is your fascination what really
you know sparks your curiosity as a kid
um you know
being the son of a technical professor
so you sort of get exposed by the way i
can tell i was never pushed in that
direction but you know i was given the
uh the opportunity and and the exposure
i think from a very young age i i was
sort of curious about
uh technology and innovation and how
things work and then how do you really
stretch boundaries and so on so uh that
is sort of has always been in there i
think that you know at a very young age
you probably you don't really know the
differences between all the different
professions and then and as i've
listened to some of the episodes and
some of the previous folks here i think
a lot of them
got to where they got you know sometimes
by chance right it's sort of a
combination of your
inner beliefs your passions but a lot of
you know being in the right place at the
right time and so on but i always knew
that something that has to do with uh
uh you know uh rational things and and
and and sort of
improving things and understanding how
things operate is is probably be in the
area of what i'm gonna do so uh that has
probably been always been in there and
from there on it's a journey of
constantly learning and improving and
better understanding what excites us
and where do you personally draw the
inspiration on a daily basis
um
again mostly uh from what i've mentioned
earlier of of innovation and what it
does to accelerate the pace of change
you know i i still remember
stories i think we all remember from
whenever whatever age we're at of our
parents telling us you know when we were
kids you know we didn't have tvs and so
on and look at what you have today and
and i can only
always try to imagine what would my kids
have and where there was so it's just
amazing to understand that it's it's
there are no boundaries right uh
whatever we do not only will it we
continue to innovate we will continue to
accelerate the pace at which change is
is is being applied and i think it's
amazing it's it's sort of the uh the
infinite power of uh of the human mind
and humanity in general
i love it
thank you very very much for these 20
minutes i really appreciate your time
thank you for having me on your
experience
but i have my last question which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself or two or four
no no that's why i it's a good thing
that i they that i prefer so you know
the first one is definitely uh innovator
or innovation you've heard me mentioning
that uh several times
uh uh the second one i think would be uh
a a learner you know i i definitely
strongly believe in constantly learning
and expanding your horizons and uh and
and continuing to improve on all fronts
and it doesn't necessarily need to be
only in professional fronts
and the third one and i think maybe
you've you've probably seen this from
the pace in which i talk is is
fast-paced you know i like to do things
quickly you know when when i'm set on
something it needs to be done now you
know it's so let's let's not let's not
dwell on it too much let's let's
understand what needs to be done and
let's
run ahead and complete it as quickly as
we can
i can definitely relate hey aaron thank
you very very much and this is wonderful
i can't wait to see you and what you'll
do with finaster and then things later
on
uh you know i think it's just an
incredible journey and i love the
innovative thinking and i love the
you know the the deep understandings
that you have about
what it takes to to reach those levels
and to do that type of innovative
thinking
and so thank you very very much and stay
safe and stay healthy thank you sure
thank
you great